Traduttore: Michele Gianella
Revisore: Nicoletta Pedrana
Buonasera.
Oggi vi parlo di intelligenza artificiale.
E vi voglio convincere che in realtà,
anche se questo termine
evoca delle immagini, o dei pensieri,
collegate a film di fantascienza,
in realtà l'intelligenza artificiale
è già nella nostra vita di tutti i giorni.
Secondo il tema di questa giornata,
già noi condividiamo
la nostra vita di tutti i giorni
con l'intelligenza artificiale.
Qui ci sono solo alcuni esempi:
ogni volta che paghiamo
con la nostra carta di credito,
c'è un algoritmo, tipico
dell'intelligenza artificiale,
che controlla se quella transazione
può essere fatta o meno;
ogni volta che usiamo
il nostro navigatore,
c'è un altro algoritmo
di intelligenza artificiale
che trova il cammino più breve
da dove siamo a dove vogliamo andare;
ogni volta che usiamo
la nostra posta elettronica,
l'intelligenza artificiale
ci aiuta a rimuovere
e a non far pervenire nella nostra inbox,
tutti quei messaggi
che non ci interessano;
ogni volta che usiamo
la nostra macchina fotografica,
se inquadriamo il viso di un'altra persona
vediamo un quadratino verde intorno
perché c'è un modulo
della macchina fotografica
che riconosce i visi;
se abbiamo un iPhone e usiamo Siri,
possiamo colloquiare con Siri,
fare domande, essere compresi
e di solito anche avere
delle risposte di buona qualità;
ogni volta che usiamo Google, o Bing,
o qualsiasi altro motore di ricerca,
anche lì le risposte che ci vengono date
vengono fornite da un algoritmo
basato su tecniche
di intelligenza artificiale;
ogni volta che compriamo
degli oggetti sul web,
usando Amazon o qualunque
altro sito per comprare,
noi non lo sappiamo
ma dietro tutta questa azione
di compravendita e di ricevere i pacchi
ci sono degli interi magazzini
completamente automatizzati -
come questi che vedete qui, di Amazon -
dove dei robot gestiscono
completamente il magazzino
per decidere che cosa mettere
dentro i pacchi, e dove spedirli.
Anche su cose non della vita
di tutti i giorni, in realtà,
c'è l'intelligenza artificiale,
come nei robot che sono andati su Marte
e che per vari anni sono riusciti
a fare varie attività
molto interessanti su Marte,
spedirci dei dati indietro
per conoscere meglio quel pianeta.
Loro sono riusciti a farlo
anche in modo parzialmente autonomo,
senza dover ricevere sempre
i comandi dalla Terra.
E questo, appunto, basandosi
sull'intelligenza artificiale.
L'ultimo esempio è quello dei suggeritori,
che noi normalmente
riceviamo tutti i giorni
quando andiamo su web
o usiamo i social media:
se noi compriamo qualcosa sul web,
o anche solo lo cerchiamo
su un motore di ricerca,
vedrete che subito dopo vi arrivano
tantissimi suggerimenti di cose simili,
che forse vi potrebbero interessare.
E anche questi, chiamati
"sistemi di raccomandazione",
sono basati sull'intelligenza artificiale.
Quindi, in realtà, la nostra vita
è pervasa dall'intelligenza artificiale,
e noi veramente
condividiamo, funzioniamo,
viviamo insieme
all'intelligenza artificiale.
In generale, noi scienziati,
chiamiamo "intelligenza artificiale"
qualunque attività di un computer
che noi normalmente assoceremmo
a un certo livello
di intelligenza in un umano.
Partiamo un po' dall'inizio,
una brevissima storia di un minuto
dell'intelligenza artificiale.
Il termine è stato coniato nel 1956,
quando un gruppo di scienziati -
tra cui questi cinque signori,
che qui sono ritratti
50 anni dopo quel momento -
hanno deciso di riunirsi,
di passare un mese insieme d'estate
per discutere insieme di come rendere
i programmi dei computer più intelligenti,
più in grado di fare cose
che normalmente farebbe un umano.
E a quell'epoca si focalizzavano
solo su alcune cose,
per esempio su aspetti di tipo matematico,
come la possibilità
per un computer, autonomamente,
di riuscire a definire, e anche a provare,
dei nuovi teoremi matematici,
cosa che normalmente farebbe, invece,
un umano e non un computer.
Da quell'epoca - questo signore qui,
con la maglia rossa,
è quello che ha coniato
il termine "intelligenza artificiale"
durante quell'incontro,
si chiama John McCarthy -
da quell'epoca questa disciplina,
l'intelligenza artificiale,
ha avuto una storia molto altalenante.
Per molti, molti casi,
in molte volte nel tempo,
ha avuto delle grandi visibilità,
delle grandi promesse,
delle grandi prospettive;
e poi, spesso,
queste sono state seguite
da delle cadute di interesse,
perché queste promesse
non sono state completamente mantenute.
Quindi, questa storia altalenante
ha continuato negli anni:
ma quello che è diverso,
adesso, che sembra essere diverso
è che c'è una convergenza
di vari fattori -
e poi cercheremo di dirvene alcuni -
che permette di convincerci che, adesso,
questa grande visibilità
dell'intelligenza artificiale,
queste grandi promesse che ci sono adesso
non saranno seguite
da una delusione successiva.
Ma invece potranno andare avanti,
con risultati sempre più eclatanti.
Questi signori, all'inizio,
erano molto ottimisti:
pensavano che nell'arco
di 10 anni, per esempio,
si sarebbe potuto costruire un programma
che potesse vincere a scacchi
contro un umano;
pensavano che in 20 anni
ci sarebbe stato un programma
che sarebbe stato in grado di effettuare
quasi tutte le attività
che un umano sa effettuare;
ma chiaramente, questo non è successo.
Tutt'ora non c'è nessun programma
che sa effettuare
tutto quello che saprebbe effettuare
un umano, anche mediocre.
A vincere a scacchi contro un umano,
però, ci siamo riusciti,
e per quello abbiamo dovuto aspettare
non solo dieci anni, ma molti di più.
Questo è successo solo nel 1997,
quando un programma chiamato "Deep Blue"
e costruito, scritto dall'IBM,
ha vinto contro il campione del mondo
di scacchi di quell'epoca,
Gerry Kasparov.
Questa è un'immagine in cui vedete
che è un po' disperato;
e quella partita, dove Deep Blue
ha vinto contro Kasparov,
è stata effettivamente una pietra miliare.
È stato molto scioccante,
per molte persone,
perché noi normalmente associamo
un livello di intelligenza molto alto
in un umano che sappia
giocare bene a scacchi.
Quindi, il fatto
che un computer potesse vincere
contro il migliore umano
che sapeva giocare a scacchi
era veramente una cosa
pensata come straordinaria.
In realtà, poi, analizzando bene le cose,
questo risultato non era poi
così straordinario,
perché è vero che noi
per giocare a scacchi bene
abbiamo bisogno di tanti aspetti
di intelligenza,
come l'intuizione,
la capacità di fare analogie,
la capacità di capire l'avversario -
insomma, tanti aspetti anche sociali
della nostra intelligenza,
che il computer non ha;
però, dalla sua, il computer
ha altre caratteristiche molto importanti
per saper giocare bene a scacchi,
che sono la grande potenza computazionale,
che cresce esponenzialmente negli anni
e che anche a quell'epoca, con i grandi
calcolatori mainframe che aveva l'IBM,
ha potuto permettere al computer
di analizzare molto in profondità
le mosse e le contromosse degli avversari.
Molto più di quanto un umano potesse fare,
anche il migliore umano
che sapeva giocare a scacchi.
Questa grande potenza
computazionale, quindi,
ha permesso al computer
di compensare la mancanza
di aspetti di intelligenza umana
che invece noi usiamo
per giocare bene a scacchi.
L'IBM è una società
che non è nuova a grandi sfide
nel campo dell'intelligenza artificiale:
questa è una di quelle.
Ma recentemente, proprio
durante questi ultimi anni,
dove c'è stata una grande visibilità
di accelerazione dei risultati
dell'intelligenza artificiale,
recentemente l'IBM ha anche dimostrato
che un computer può fare di più
che semplicemente vincere
un gioco contro un umano.
E nel 2011, infatti, un altro programma,
scritto sempre
da dei ricercatori dell'IBM,
ha vinto contro i migliori campioni umani
a un gioco televisivo
che c'è negli Stati Uniti
che si chiama Jeopardy!
Questo gioco è molto semplice:
per saper giocare bene al gioco
bisogna, semplicemente,
rispondere a tantissime domande
su tante categorie della conoscenza umana.
E non solo, però,
bisogna saper rispondere bene -
e quindi, per saper rispondere bene,
bisogna saper leggere
tanta informazione testuale,
assimilarla, capirla,
capirne il significato
e fare possibilmente collegamenti
tra tutti questi libri che si leggono.
E quindi, già questo
è un risultato entusiasmante,
che un computer potesse
effettivamente prendere questa -
tutti questi testi,
questa informazione testuale,
capirne il significato
e collegare le cose tra loro.
Ma non solo: per giocare bene,
bisogna anche saper valutare
quanto si è preparati
in una certa categoria di domande,
perché durante il gioco, a un certo punto,
bisogna scommettere parte dei soldi
che abbiamo accumulato
che si saprà rispondere bene
alla prossima domanda
in una certa categoria.
Quindi, bisogna saper valutare
quanto si è preparati
per poter rispondere
alle domande successive.
E anche qui, chiaramente,
questa è una parte fondamentale del gioco,
perché se non si scommette bene,
nel momento giusto, la quantità giusta,
chiaramente si può perdere
anche se in effetti si è preparati.
E quindi, questi due aspetti
hanno dimostrato
che anche un computer come Watson,
che alla fine poi ha vinto,
in questo incontro
questi due campioni umani,
era in grado di raggiungere
queste due modalità di ragionamento:
assimilazione di grande quantità testuali,
per saper rispondere bene alle domande;
ma anche valutazione
di tipo possibilistico
delle possibilità
di rispondere bene alle domande.
Di esempi di intelligenza artificiale
ce ne sono tanti,
questo dimostra che un computer
sa capire quello che noi scriviamo;
ma anche, ultimamente,
si è capito che un computer
riesce a comprendere
non solo quello che scriviamo,
ma anche le immagini che noi produciamo.
Quella che si chiama
la visione automatica,
cioè di un computer
che sa guardare un'immagine,
e capire quello che c'è dentro,
ha avuto una grandissima
accelerazione, ultimamente.
Qui, per esempio, ci sono alcune immagini:
e le diciture, le descrizioni,
vengono scritte non da un umano,
ma da un computer.
E vedete che sono molto precise,
quindi facendoci capire
che i computer sanno vedere
quello che c'è in una immagine,
che per un computer all'inizio
è semplicemente una sequenza di pixel.
E non solo vedere
tutti gli oggetti che ci sono,
ma anche le relazioni tra loro.
E questo chiaramente
ha grande possibilità,
ha potere applicativo:
pensate semplicemente ad un cieco
che riceve un'immagine
e che può in effetti
vederla, questa immagine,
perché il computer gliela descrive.
Un altro esempio di grande sinergia,
tra tante tecnologie
di intelligenza artificiale
è quello delle auto che riescono
a guidare da sole, nel traffico,
senza l'uso di un guidatore umano.
Queste sono un vero concentrato
di tecniche di intelligenza artificiale,
perché hanno bisogno di vedere da sole
quello che c'è intorno a loro:
i segnali stradali, i pedoni,
le altre macchine.
Ma non solo vederle:
prevedere quello che questi oggetti,
e queste persone, e queste auto
faranno in futuro,
e in modo da poter rispondere
con la migliore azione da intraprendere
in risposta a queste previsioni.
E devono inoltre essere in grado
di reagire molto velocemente
a delle situazioni non previste,
e anche possibilmente critiche.
Queste sono due immagini,
una dell'auto di Google,
e una di quella di Tesla;
ma ci sono tanti altri;
la tecnologia è molto, molto vicina
per essere portata sul mercato.
E sicuramente queste auto
saranno molto, molto più sicure
delle auto guidate da un umano,
perché non si stancano,
non si addormentano,
non guidano parlando al cellulare
o parlando con il passeggero
e tutte queste cose che sono causa
di tantissime vittime della strada.
Quindi, spero di avervi convinto
che anche adesso noi siamo immersi
in una società piena
di intelligenza artificiale;
ma il futuro lo sarà sempre di più.
Nel futuro noi condivideremo
veramente tutto
con questo uso pervasivo
dell'intelligenza artificiale,
dove noi e le macchine intelligenti
saremo, e siamo tuttora,
molto complementari.
Abbiamo delle intelligenze
molto complementari
che se riusciremo, sinergicamente,
a compenetrare
riusciremo veramente a fare del meglio
per la società e per noi umani.
Non credo che il futuro sia un futuro
dove le macchine intelligenti
ci rimpiazzeranno,
ma invece dove amplificheranno
il nostro tipo di intelligenza.
Per poter arrivare
a questo tipo di futuro, però,
a questa situazione così ideale,
c'è bisogno di dare alle macchine
le possibilità di prendere
delle decisioni autonomamente,
perché altrimenti non potranno essere
veramente intelligenti,
non potranno esprimersi al meglio;
e queste decisioni che prenderanno
autonomamente, però,
bisogna essere sicuri
che le prendano nel modo giusto.
Cioè bisogna assicurarci
che nello sviluppare,
nello scrivere il codice per costruire
queste macchine intelligenti,
noi dobbiamo assicurarci
che loro lo facciano:
sì, raggiungendo gli obiettivi
che noi gli abbiamo dato;
ma soprattutto, seguendo
dei principi etici e dei valori morali
che siano allineati
con quelli degli umani.
E quindi dobbiamo essere
sicuri e tranquilli,
e solo questo ci darà la tranquillità
per poter dare loro il controllo
di prendere delle decisioni autonome.
Questo è l'argomento
di un progetto di ricerca
che ho recentemente iniziato,
che è stato finanziato
da una fondazione americana
e che comprende tantissime persone:
anche un filosofo, uno psicologo,
persone di informatica,
persone che hanno lavorato alla NASA
e che si occupano di missioni
in situazioni critiche,
perché pensiamo che veramente,
in questo sforzo di inserire
dentro le macchine intelligenti
i principi etici e valori morali
simili a quelli umani
sia necessario uno sforzo collettivo
di tante discipline.
E pensiamo di riuscirci - chiaramente,
non sarà un lavoro che sarà finito
una volta che il nostro progetto
sarà arrivato alla fine:
si avranno bisogno di tantissimi progetti,
di tantissimi altri ricercatori.
Ma siamo veramente ottimisti
che questo possa essere fatto.
E quando si arriverà a questo risultato,
allora veramente potremmo dire
di essere in una società
dove le macchine e gli uomini
si aiutano l'un l'altro.
E dove le macchine potranno, anche,
aiutarci a darci più tempo,
effettuando dei lavori che, normalmente,
noi effettueremmo da soli,
darci più tempo per noi.
Più tempo per i nostri cari,
più tempo per capire noi stessi,
i nostri desideri, i nostri bisogni.
E soprattutto, più tempo
per capire veramente cosa ci rende umani.
Quindi io non sono preoccupata
che l'intelligenza artificiale elimini,
distrugga la nostra umanità,
ma anzi il contrario:
penso che l'intelligenza artificiale
ci aiuterà a capire meglio
che cos'è che ci rende umani.
Grazie.
(Applausi)